[Musique]
la règle et c'est surtout connu comme un
bonbon aux différentes formes couleurs
et saveurs
mais cette friandise de notre enfance
est en fait à l'origine une plante
médicinale la réglisse est une plante
mais parfois en n'oubliant pas ce qu'on
mange un bâton de réglisse
on oppose nécessairement la plante qui
nous vient à l'esprit mais l'arrivée son
plan une plante de la famille des
faibles une fabacées et c'est une plante
qui est plus tropical on en cultive mu
sir david marie provost et herboriste
c'est ici dans les serres de la clé des
champs que poussent les différentes
plantes médicinales comme la réglisse
envoie look si les chenilles qui ont
démarré
celle ci c'est le premier lot de
réglisse alors ses skis sortie du du
premier ce nid mais s'est tout récemment
d'arrivée c'est une plante qui est
vraiment très très très fragile très
sensible donc on est dans le début de
printemps ici on a fait le premier s'est
mis ensuite on va la mettre en terre fin
juin début juillet et elle va passer
quelques années en terre avant qu'on
puisse la récolter
après plusieurs années ce que l'on
récolte c'est l'horizon la racine de la
plante une si je fais breuses aux
allures d'un morceau de bois originaire
de la méditerranée on en trouve aussi au
moyen-orient en asie
françois dufour et acheteurs à la clé
des champs ils ouvrent les sacs de riz
glisse provenance d'égypte donc les
ventes ont pris dans ce format là on va
regarder de quoi ils ont l'air est ce
qu'ils ont l'air endommagée on voyait
aller aussi à l'odeur puis parfois
dépendant des produits et parfois aussi
on va se mettre à la haye a ajouté
donc on peut et d'alcool la réglisse il
faut la marche est la règle et sans
bâton comme ça il faut la manche un peu
pour avoir son goût qui ressort en bâton
en copeaux ou réduites en poudre la
réglisse et transformé pour faire
différentes préparations médicinales
comme des extraits liquide
mais philippe de vienne lui l'utilisent
comme épice c'est un peu comme une
feuille de laurier
on va la mettre dans un plat de long
cuisson pour infuser lentement mais on
peut aussi la résurgence pause avec un
petit moulin à café elektric parce que
sinon c'est ça peut s' est assez dure
c'est du bois et cette poudre là on peut
la soupe ou dhr et au dernier moment que
ça va donner un peu d'arômes merveilleux
et sa voix sucrée les plats de manière
qui est très différente du sucre blanc
et ridley site est une plante médicinale
avant de devenir un bonbon et c'est à
une époque où les pharmaciens qu'on
appelait des apothicaires fabriquer des
pastilles avec la réglisse
au départ ce bonbon était destiné à
soigner et les gens l'ont tellement aimé
qu'ils les c'est devenu un bonbon il n'y
a plus
fraîchement il n'y a plus de vrais
réglisse dans la réglisse onu que le
goût mais on n'a pas vraiment les
presser d'actifs n'agrée directives de
la réglisse à des biais faire reconnus
pour les infections des voies
respiratoires ainsi que pour la
digestion
mais qu'en est il des bonbons on a
apporté différents produits ou
pharmacologue pierre haddad majorité des
produits de confiserie de nos jours
utilisent plutôt l'huile d'année skull
les extraits de réglisse pour donner
cette saveur anisée justement associé à
l'alaric de ce mois et donc les
bienfaits de la réglisse
mais celle-là plante elle-même ne sont
pas présents effectivement alors les
gens qui disent on aime pas la réglisse
ce qu'il n'est probablement pas celle à
l'étoile et qui est très puissant donc
en route la vraie règle isbu gens sont
surpris parce qu'au début ou le match il
n'y a aucune mon goût et c'est dans le
machin qu'on a la saveur qui se
développe c'est une saveur délicate qui
restent longtemps en bouche et qui donne
une douceur agréable en bouche
aujourd'hui encore certains bonbons
contiennent des exprès de réglisse theft
avec havre est arrivé sain et à leurs
voeux postale est ce un bon donc on a
juste eu quelques secrets intérieurs
pour le rendre délicieux goût nous en
occident on voit plutôt leur église
comme étant quelque chose qu'on
associait que les choses sucrées les
bonbons les gâteaux les crèmes glacées
et c'est en asie on le voit plus sentir
les chinois plus en combinaison avec des
viandes forte et d'autres épices pour
faire des sondés aigre-doux ad braisé si
tu veux des glaces et montures dans sa
cuisine philippe devienne utilisent des
copeaux de réglisse c'est même le de ces
ingrédients secrets j'admets ça fait
trente albums et slovènes je mette la
réglisse ils sont tous cas le va être
encore ces procès c'est le secret la
règle et c'est un fusée dans le bouillon
avec de la cannelle zeste d'orange
échalotes un peu de poivre et du vin ça
nous notre sucre et donc quand même
chose assez de ces déséquilibres et
surtout la réglisse à la capacité de
comme rassembler les saveurs de
déséquilibré alors c'est vraiment
inspirant de voir que ça peut se
maintenir le plus zen et en médecine
tâches ou lehman bros
[Musique]